one of the stranger but more useful
suggestions of psychotherapy and in
particular a branch of it known as
transactional analysis is that all of us
contain within ourselves three essential
personalities a child a parent and an
adult to flesh these out a little the
child is typically vulnerable touching
trusting weak in need incapable of
properly looking after themselves and
crying out for assistance tenderness
support structure and some rules for
their part the parent is strong dominant
in control responsible but also often
chiding critical in hectoring and busy
from all their cares and duties
meanwhile the adult is sane thoughtful
in command neither too weak nor too
strong creative and kind
in an Ideal World we would all be able
to toggle between these three
personality types with relative ease in
a good relationship we would constantly
be moving between all three roles in
ourselves mostly hovering in the adult
Zone but able when occasions demand this
to go into parent or child mode for
example when we're feeling sad and Under
Pressure it should be part of Health to
know how to become a child again that is
to show our need ask for help curl into
a ball become small and trust that we
can be met with kindness and sympathy
without fearing attack or belittlement
then again there should also be moments
in a relationship particularly when our
usually adult partner has hit a crisis
and descended into a childlike mode when
we are powerfully able to step up into a
parental role and become ministering
indulgent to weakness and Tantrums calm
in the face of irrationality and secure
enough in ourselves to know that the
child partner will in a little while
revert back to the maturity and
self-command that we typically expect
from them
if a couple have small children then for
long stretches both people may need to
act as parent but then once the kids are
in bed they might both have a go at
being sweet slightly naughty children or
one might play adult to the other ones
needy younger self
the difficulty for couples and
individuals is when people get stuck in
particular positions when they can only
ever be children or only ever parents or
only ever adults there are relationships
where for example one partner is always
child and the other is always parent one
person is forever being a bit
irresponsible a bit naughty they leave
their clothes everywhere they don't book
in for driving lessons they don't go to
the dry cleaners they forget to do the
shopping and they lose the keys the can
be highly endearing when one's in the
mood but you'd hesitate a lot before
leaving them in charge and on the other
side of the Ledger there is in such
relationships often a parental type
partner who is always chiding always
reminding the child what to do super
competent forever rather stressed
alternately indulgent to the child but
also on the edge of being cross and
punitive
associated with this can be a deep
reluctance on the part of the parental
figure ever to access their own child
self they always have to be strong they
always have to be mummy and daddy they
cannot go anywhere near being baby
why we might ask do people and therefore
couples get stuck in these roles why can
it be so hard to move out of them why
are some people rigidly incapable of
feeling their way into the role of be it
parent or child or adult in all cases we
are typically looking at something in
the past which has made an easy
transition to a particular position
untenable or frightening there are
people stuck in the child role for whom
adulthood and Parenthood present
insuperable difficulties perhaps they
are The Offspring of a loving parent who
couldn't tolerate their maturity to be
deemed worthy of Love they had to stay a
baby or else alternatively one may feel
one has to stay stuck in the child mode
because a parent would be angry
castrating and humiliating if one dared
to show Independence and pride in one's
adult ideals
at the other end of the spectrum very
poignantly there are people whose
younger selves were so badly treated who
experience such anxiety and lack of
support when they were children that the
idea of being small even for a few hours
presents unbearable challenges to their
integrity they may be very happy playing
mummy and daddy what they cannot ever do
is be baby
the root out of all these impasses is as
always self-exploration and mutual
honesty in relationships problems are
never as bad as they might be once we
get them into Consciousness and
circulate them in discussion to admit to
being a child who doesn't dare to be an
adult or a parent who doesn't dare to be
a child isn't Just A peculiar sounding
confession it suggests the presence of
someone profoundly committed to eventual
maturity and on their way to being the
best kind of grown-up